today I want to talk about designing
even larger
is actually a sequel to talk I gave a
jessica of Australia two years ago and
just like that last time I want to kind
of ground this talk in our career
progression as software engineers
I think many of you in the audience
would maybe call yourself a senior self
engineer or if you're not there yet you
aspire to be one and so the way I would
describe what it means to be seen
yourself engineer is that if someone
comes to me and they say like hey you
know I'm out to do this project in this
domain that you already filming you with
you would say yeah that's actually
something I know how to do I don't need
to need anyone else's help
I'm a senior person I know how to do it
and then this was kind of the series of
my last remark was going beyond that and
with that software engineering lens but
I'm not talking so much about people but
still you kind of transcend beyond
yourself right it doesn't
the only looking at solving problems
yourself you're looking at how can i as
a software engineer anticipate our
others two things and then design api's
accordingly so that they are more
successful right so I think that is
really beyond seniority in this talk
today I want to go one level beyond that
I want to breach this stage where I can
say I can design software such that for
loops of engineers the probability
increases that the suffer that they
produce is good now there are three key
words here first of all large groups of
engineers so if you're working to
startup or like a three-person company
then this talk may seem superfluous
boring and extra like not something you
care about but I think many of you may
be working insurance companies bangs or
anything right like wherever you have a
bunch of folks and multiple teams and
you kind of kinda need to coordinate
stuff then I'm talking about probability
there's no security here right you can
only try to set things up so they'll
probably work but there's no guarantees
there's no silver bullets finally I want
to talk about good stuff here so this is
not a product management
all right this talk will not help you
write the right program but it will help
you write that program good so what I
mean is it being maintainable high
performance having low buck density
being delivered on time that type of
stuff right these qualities that
transcend the product aspect of software
engineering I want to clarify one more
thing I'm gonna say stuff like
frameworks software infrastructure other
stuff like that all the time I kind of
treat them interchangeably what I mean
is kind of suffer that we are building
that helps other people build better
software and what I would like you all
to kind of put your mind into like
you're the person in your company who's
responsible for kind of defining how
people write software and then write the
infrastructure the software that they
are using to write software and when I
say you build a framework but I don't
mean that you make your own react or
angular right maybe that's actually the
right way to do it but it's not
necessary right I think whenever you
have a larger set of teams you want to
kind of standardize how they build
applications and that kind of puts a
framework around how people buy build
applications so that's what I mean again
like think about you being the person
who's responsible for this and then this
talk is about how you are successful at
that job and I'm going to talk about
that in three chapters the first one I
call understanding the degree of
uncertainty then we're going to learn
how to solve all known problems and then
final are we going to learn about
deploying change cool let's dive right
in with our friends or in our Heisenberg
telling us that this is actually
impossible
understanding the degree of uncertainty
how far are we that what's actually
needed to be done is the thing that's
needed to be done that is absolutely key
for self engineering I'm going to talk
about a technique to kind of understand
how well we understand things for that
we need to understand the problem space
really well and understand how well we
understand this sorry about the busy
slides these are just a few questions
basically and the answers aren't even
that important but ask yourself what is
what is it in the existing
infrastructure that your users and your
users or developers what are they
struggling with and how are they
struggling with it what is the class of
applications that folk
we'll built using your work and kind of
bra terms what are the trends in the
industry that influence what type of
software is probably going to be written
in the future
right because infrastructure is always
for future software now all of these you
know may sound like reading the tea
leaves but I think usually you know if
you've been doing this for a while you
actually might have answers and so the
key here is really you do this exercise
to understand like how well can you
answer this right that's really the key
like if this is like really easy and you
write it down and everything is clear
that's one side or the other side is
like no I actually have no idea how they
answer this question I know nothing even
more powerful than knowing what people
want to do is what they don't want to do
so these are non goals so what are non
goals non goals aren't you know let's
say you work for a manufacturing company
and you don't need to like build an
insurance piece of software right that's
not an ondol
that's ridiculous of course you don't
want to do this right an on goal is
something that it's actually super
reasonable and even likely that you want
to do it but you know you don't want to
do it right like it's not a requirement
and so this might even be more difficult
than answering and like if you if you're
able to answer these questions that can
be very powerful you know the degree of
uncertainty is low so why why is
uncertainty so so so important when
uncertainty is hot you're gonna have to
make trade-offs you need to be flexible
right you need to say okay I need to I
don't know whether I need to support
this so I better make it that it's
possible right and whenever you're in
that situation
you need to make trade-offs right so
trade-offs are situations where you need
to kind of square to things and make
them both possible and probably end up
with something that's not quite as
awesome is something that only needs do
one of those two things and the problem
with trade-offs is that they make stuff
difficult and when you have unnecessary
trade-offs that really breaks software
engineering like software engineering
hates unnecessary trade-off and it's the
root of all evil what is an example for
this let's say
in your company you built this
infrastructure for mobile apps and you
anticipate that you know if maybe the
salespeople they have old crappy Android
phones with low memory and so you need
to make it such that everything works in
the whole memory situation and to design
the software frameworks such as
everyone's going and like needs to kit
worry about memory and manage it and
like all that stuff right and then it
turns out your company goes and buys
never on your phone and that was
completely for nothing right that's an
unnecessary trade-off but it's now much
more difficult to write software in your
system because it's in theory possible
to run in these lower power devices and
so interestingly this is a bit of a
generalization of Donald Knuth famous
theorem premature optimization is the
root of all evil
right so premature optimization is just
a special case of an unnecessary
trade-off but it doesn't only have to be
about performance every time you make
your software do something that it
doesn't need to do you made an
unnecessary trade-off in the baseline of
software design that can be really
really fatal cool so I think that's a
bit of a web development conference I
wanted to have one slide about web
development we have been doing web
frameworks for a few years right like
it's been over 20 years now and we
actually understand how to build web
frameworks really well and if we don't
and if we do a bad job it's our fault
but it's not because we don't understand
how to do this
maybe we personally like the experience
but we could do a really good job right
so that's that's where the degree of
uncertainty is actually quite low like
we know how to build web apps on the
other hand imagine it's 2015 and your
mother comes and says hey I want you to
build infrastructure for building deep
learning and you're like well I have
never done this before like no one in my
company has ever done it before there's
like three blog posts about it then the
degree of uncertainty is really high
right and you won't be able to build
infrastructure that's quite as nice
right and so obviously it's always going
to be a range between like we understand
this really well we don't understand it
at all but it's really important in
software engineering that you can deal
with uncertainty right there's always
going to be something that you don't
know and they need to be able to live in
that in that space
so the reason why it's so important to
understand the degree of uncertainty is
because it allows us to then tailor the
application to that concerning to you
and the way we do it is by tailoring the
degree of abstraction how abstract are
we making stuff for our developers and
let me get something out of the way
abstractions are awesome you want to
abstract everything as much as possible
because abstractions make it really
expressive he can do exactly what you
want it's really fast you don't have to
write as much code everything's great
right except when that abstraction is
the wrong abstraction that gets in your
way right you go in that abstraction
doesn't do what you want so you have to
work around it you have to like kind of
beat to it and like make it do what you
want and everything is painful and
terrible and not what you want right
like that's that's bad so if you
understand how well you understand the
problem space you can tailor the
abstraction to that degree of
uncertainty and if you think you know I
don't actually understand that so well
you will reduce the degree of
abstraction right so that's that's
really the key how well do you
understand what you need to do if you
don't understand it do City grab
subsection wait wait do you agree that's
that's her kind of the random picture
anyway cool so kind of the summary here
being like go take the time to
understand how well you know things and
then tailor stuff towards it again it's
always going to be the case that we have
to deal with some uncertainty so it's
really useful that there's a set of
techniques that's always good we can
solve all known problems in software
engineering I'm going to present four
techniques to do this again no matter
how little you know you always want to
do these four things the first one is
optimizing iteration velocity so we're
the mean with this is developer and you
hit safe in your editor how long does it
take to go from that moment until you
find out whether that was a good change
right and there's on one hand you have
the super awesome hot coat really don't
su type everything updates on screen
magic and the other hand you like
manually go to the console Kindle your
job or application server recompile
everything it takes 20 minutes to
startup right that's kind of the the
range and I think probably many of you
can feel with me you've been somewhere
between these these two two extremes now
that's obviously nice for something to
be fast but the reality is slow
iteration cycles actually introduce
trade-offs into our software design if
it takes a long time to find out that
you've made a mistake
mistakes are expensive as a software
designer the professional thing to do is
them to go and say like I have to design
this API so that no one can ever get it
wrong in their usage right because if
they get it wrong it's so expensive
right so how do you even do that that
nobody can misuse your API it's really
difficult right so if on the other hand
everything's super fast people can
explore explore stuff do things you know
figure things out because the cost of
failure is so low then you as a designer
of that API can say okay maybe it's fine
for people to do a bit more exploring
here so the message is make iteration
cycles fast very similar is the aspect
of debug ability so it's a framework
author it's actually in your hand to you
know control how hard it is to debug a
system
maybe you design this like awesome but
like complex blackbox state machine that
no one can figure out it's just random
things sometimes the right ones but
sometimes not but nobody knows why right
maybe your stack traces are super long
and confuse people or maybe on the other
side you put in this like really
sensible logging and tracing framework
and people understand what's going on
they make a mistake it's fine they're
you know they fix it no problem similar
to debug ability you're in control of
how testable your system is
like maybe in your framework it's really
difficult to instantiate a system to the
state where then someone goes and write
a unit test right or maybe it's really
easy and if it's easy to test the system
someone can go and like make sure what
they did is right and you know again
it's much easier to write to built in
that system without understanding
everything so well cool we don't have
three topics that are more only like
software side of the world the fourth
topic for solving all known problems is
slightly different
it's empathy so as engineers and
software engineers who build software
for software engineers I mentioned this
in my last talk that's really empathy on
easy mode right like we can understand
how other software engineers field we
run ourselves much more likely that our
own intuition is actually the right one
that if we try to have empathy with like
a some more random person who we don't
understand or we don't know their
background right that's really helpful
and can do really well today I want to
talk about a very special aspect of
empathy if you're designer of a
framework you could build the perfect
application with it right you know
everything about it you can do get
everything right it's like very little
code everything is perfect but every
other person who will ever use it will
know less about it right and so think
about what it means to not know
everything about a piece of software
right think about how you can make an
API robust towards not knowing
everything and you know their end result
will be that people will just be much
happier users of your application cool
so now we learned how to solve all known
problems of software engineering let's
go to the final chapter which is
deploying change the so this is really
really really key what I like to say
that you know software infrastructure
that has no usage has no impact which
seems obvious right but it's so common
in this field
the people built ivory towers right
where you have a team and they go in
like they've built something awesome and
they're really excited about it and you
know it being fun to build it was
probably a reason why they did it and
then they come and say like hey I have a
thing and you're like but that doesn't
do what I want right and then everyone's
sad and they move on to the next ivory
tower right so if you want to
professionalize this that is not the
right way to do it right getting your
stuff adopted is everything and it's a
big part of your job so much though that
my first advice for how to get this
right is actually totally in the realm
of marketing right so software engineers
again they're human beings they want to
work on stuff that's cool and that they
heard about on Twitter and that's
exciting right so it's fine to go and
put the stuff they want in your
infrastructure right like they they all
like it more and then they use it more
and everyone's happy and if that's not
the worst unnecessary trade-off in the
world then it's just okay right cool so
that's more on the marketing side let's
go to some bit more serious topic which
is that adopting software is easier if
you can do incremental adoption what
this means is that instead of going like
Haley's new framework rewrite everything
from scratch in two years and hopefully
it's good to make incremental progress
as you kind of work on it like have
something after months after something
after two months you know and and you
know I think basically even if you start
with that major rewrite at some point
someone's gonna say like we need to have
something in production alright we can't
go on like this where we kind of do
everything twice for like that whole
period of time right so this is really
something that if you want your stuff
adopted it's a key that you allow for
incremental adoption first technique
here is really concrete just think about
two different scenarios
the first is composition of your new
framework code into a legacy code let's
say you haven't gotten around to like
rewriting the app shell yet everything's
still kind of the old way you did it
but the team comes and says I'm going to
build that you feature in the new
framework and so your framework is
designed such that they can kind of live
inside the old codebase right that's
composition into legacy code and then
there's the other side which is
composition of legacy code into your
codebase let's say you have is like
super ultra customized business-critical
jQuery datepicker right and and and
people want to have it right and they
want to keep it and so you you design
your framework such that that jQuery
thing which probably valid and violates
all the assumptions you ever made still
works right that is composition of
legacy code if your new code base both
of these things put trade-off pressure
on your system because suddenly all
these all these assumptions are no
longer valid but but it's probably worth
it because it allows people to
incrementally adopt your software second
technique I call temporary imperfection
so again as a framework author you
probably have this like really idealized
view of the world like how people build
software using your thing and then it
comes crashing down in thing when people
do incremental adoption because not
everything is great so my advice would
be to do the following write a Lynch
rule using is Lind or something like
that that identifies the old way of
doing something right and then when
someone when there's code in the code
base that isn't not the new way you get
an error message
hopefully that error message also says
you know this is no longer the right way
of doing it here are pointers to
documentation how to do it right that's
step one you have this lint rule step
two is to then go and allow all existing
violations saying okay here's like 500
times where people do it wrong
it's all fine right like these are all
allowed now you're in a state where all
new code has to comply with a new way of
doing it and this is really powerful
because there might be all these
engineers in your organization who
haven't really read the email where they
were told that they need to do something
differently they haven't come to your
talk right
but these know they get an error message
and they are ok cool I can I can do it
you weigh right it's really powerful the
other thing that's kind of interesting
inside said this allow list which you've
probably checked into your git
repository it's a lecture of technical
debt right technical depth can be this
like abstract concept that you know you
have and it's probably out there
somewhere but like really difficult to
nail down where it is right but this is
loudest like you literally know in file
X line 15
there's my technical debt right and now
you can pay it off you can maybe have a
you know team fix it where you say like
one week we're just going to go at this
list and like it's gonna be gone after
that week and we're all happy right so
that's really I think it's a powerful
way to think about like materializing
technical debt is something that's like
very concrete just like depth on your
bank account you have this modest cool
next technique which is key for for
getting my adoption is to try for
automated migration right it's not gonna
get you all the way but it's pretty
powerful
this for example GS code shift from
Facebook but basically you're kind of
described a pattern this is the old way
visiting your way you get from her from
A to B it's great again this is possibly
problematic right it puts trait of
pressure on your on your new API because
now the new API has to basically be
happy with what was already in the code
but it can't really add new stuff in
this mechanism but it might be worth it
because you know no one has to do that
work manually it's probably going to
make people more happy than having to do
everything by themselves alright moving
on from these like more software things
it's like a little bit more about humans
I think the one thing I would like to
take everyone away from this talk is
that when you're in this role of being
like the person responsible for the
software infrastructure you always need
a customer zero right that is what's
going to that's the antidote to the
ivory tower the customer zero what it's
going to happen is they're going to be
the first customer we're going to who's
going to use your thing and build a real
product and what you need to do is you
go and sit with them to pay programming
or not like but at least be there and
like go build it with them right this is
before you declare it you're done right
because now you can validate your
assumption you can find corner cases and
you can help like you can iterate on
your framework until it's actually good
it might not have been there right now
this first customer should not be a
migration speech chump it should be
something you build from scratch because
when you know migrations are always
gonna be somewhat painful and long
winding and you know why would you
migrate to something that might not even
be what you want yet right so you need
quick feedback cycles at that point but
this will be really crucial to really
ensure that what you're building is good
another important piece of advice is one
of the ironic things is that if you
never build anything with your thing how
do you even build right the
documentation for how to build something
with it right like how to how to how to
write the onboarding dog to start from
scratch if you've never done it right so
if you go and have a customer's ear and
you work with them that's the one time
chance you really get to write that
onboarding dog right so don't don't miss
it
now because there's all that kind of
designed for large organizations there's
gonna be some organizational challenges
is finding a customers you're right you
might not find that team that's like
cool with working with it's unproven
unstable and like probably not even good
piece of framework right so what do you
do to get that customer zero that that's
the right one for you what I've found is
that there's typically a team that likes
to be on the cutting edge right one of
the things you can pitch is to say hey
you'll eventually have to migrate to
this because that's the future why don't
you want to be on the new thing already
so you save that step right that could
be very attractive for it to him and you
can argue because I'm gonna sit with you
I'm gonna actually tailor or make this
framework to do what you want right you
were you're privileged over any future
user who will just have to kind of deal
with what what it is because I'm going
to like realize okay it's not perfect
for this use case and I'm gonna make it
perfect right this can be really
powerful even considering all the
downsides now maybe that doesn't work in
that case your organization has to be
made
mature enough to accept that we will
have to be a mandate right there will
have to be the time or you say you
actually have to use this right and and
that can be can be confusing for
organization but it's so important
because if you have it the alternative
is that the infrastructure team is just
going to go and build ivory towers and
everyone's unhappy right so yeah well
it's still better to mandate that
somewhat to use yourself dock for your
stuff and not doing it all all right we
have our first customer eventually you
will have to do the first migration and
once again it's actually your job to do
this migration together with that team
that actually wants to do it so they're
migrating to your framework the reason
why it's so key that you do this
yourself is you have that point B that's
the future to your framework and you
have to point a that's where the team is
right if you're not there that team will
go and say hey I need to go to point B
it's difficult but I'll figure it out
they kind of take it as god given like
because they take your infrastructure
it's kind of being there right you can
be like hmm
I could make that one change here and
would be so much easier and because I
have this all in my head I know what
what's possible to change and because
you're a lazy person you're gonna make
that migration you're really easy and
that is going to help everyone who comes
after you have a much better time right
cool these were the things I want to
talk about just let me summarize really
quick the first thing we need to do is
we understand the problem space and then
tailor our abstractions to that degree
of uncertainty even if uncertainty is
high we want to solve all known problems
you might remember that increase
interracial velocity make the ability
great testability great and have an
empathy with your users and then finally
nothing here matters if you don't focus
on team adoption pick yourself a likable
focus on incremental adoption and get
those customer a migration zero folks
that's all I had today thank you very
much
you